hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in sermon number 16 on the gospel of
Matthew which is focused on chapter five
of that text John chrysostom is going to
be focusing primarily on the verses that
have to do with anger and trying to
explain that to his audience but prior
to that he is going to engage in a sort
of Defense of both what he calls the Old
Law and the precepts that Christ is
giving in The Sermon on the Mount that
are taking the Law that's provided in
the Torah and also exemplified you could
say in the prophets and going further
with it and the homily Begins by quoting
think not that I am come to destroy the
law or the prophets right and what is
chrysostom's point in doing this well
he's got several different
audiences in mind
um you know he's primarily talking to
Christians but this is within a context
in which there's a lot of Christian
Jewish polemics still going on and
Christianity has become you could say
divided into a number of different
sects or communities
one of which is particularly important
as an adversary and that is the
manichaeans one of the Gnostic sects and
so
chrysostom is going to be defending you
know Orthodox Christianity the sort of
mainstream views against those so we've
got this context of the Jewish law
Sermon on the Mount talking about that
providing some amplifications and then
the mannequins
and you see this in section three where
he says think not that I am come to
destroy he's subjoined I'm not come to
destroy but to fulfill and he says now
this not only obstructs the obstinacy of
the Jews who would be saying yeah you
know you don't need all this extra stuff
that Jesus is bringing but stops the
mouths of those Heretics who say that
the old Covenant is of the devil for if
Christ came to destroy his tyranny how
is this covenant not only not destroyed
but even fulfilled by him and then he
says Christ said not only I do not
destroy it though this had been enough
but I even fulfill it so this is a third
option you could say between old law is
good follow the Old Law old law is bad
which is what the mannequins are saying
get rid of it this Jesus person is
coming to provide a new way of thinking
about things a new way of live living
yes coming from a Jewish Matrix but
leaving that behind and then Christians
who are saying no no both of these we we
actually want to have both of these
they're connected together and so you
know there's this emphasis on not
destroying the law but fulfilling it and
what does that mean so he goes out and
he says well how one may ask did he not
destroy it in what way did he rather
fulfill either the law or the prophets
and at first at this point in the sermon
or homily chrysostom is going to say
well there's three main ways and then as
is so usual for people when they make a
list he comes up with some additional
ones as well the first is he says well
um the prophets he fulfilled in as much
as he confirmed by his actions all that
had been said concerning him
the Evangelist used to say in each case
that it might be fulfilled which was
spoken by the prophet and that probably
except for certain kinds of Christians
less interesting less attractive uh you
know in in the present but it was it was
very persuasive in the past
probably more important is the second
thing that he points out
so he says
the law he fulfilled not in one way only
but a second and third in One Way by
transgressing none of the precepts of
the law for that he did fulfill it all
hear what he said to John for it thus it
becomes becometh us to fulfill all
righteousness and to the Jews he also
said which of you convicts me of sin and
to his disciples the prince of this
world cometh and findeth nothing in me
so you know Jesus is following the Old
Law rather than destroying it and then
adding additional important precepts to
it as by way of fulfilling it and then
interestingly chrysostom says that Jesus
makes it possible for others to fulfill
the law right he says this was a another
sense he did the same through us all so
this is the Marvel that he himself not
only himself fulfilled it but he granted
this to us likewise so he in whatever
way we're going to explain this
according to chrysostom Christ is making
it possible for those within his
community or perhaps everybody to
fulfill the the law
at the same time because of what Christ
is saying specifically in relation to
the law the law is becoming you could
say a bigger code right and it's going
further than it did in the past we can
talk about additional precepts and so he
says you'll find another sense in which
this has been done what sort in the
sense of that future code of laws which
he was about to deliver to him for his
sayings were no repeal of the earlier
law but a drawing out and filling up of
them thus not to kill is not a null by
the saying be not angry but is filled up
and put in Greater security and so of
all the others and he um
chrysostom says that you know at first
in preaching this because this is like
you know not at the very beginning of
The Sermon on the Mount this is after
some other things have been laid out
he's like well if you'd like read
between the lines and think about the
applications you're going to see that
you know what's being said in terms of I
say to you here's the new rule is
already in there say for example in the
Beatitudes at the very beginning of The
Sermon on the Mount and so you know if
we go on with this uh what are these
additional precepts supposed to do well
he talks for a little bit about like if
you're breaking these precepts you're
going to be one of the least in the
Kingdom of Heaven or you might not even
get in why well because you actually
have to be following the law for you
know what the law is about righteousness
or Justice is another way of putting it
and he tells his followers and this is
you know kind of a contemporary issue
right he says unless your righteousness
exceeds the righteousness of the scribes
and the Pharisees you're not going to
enter into the Kingdom of Heaven this is
an important thing to think about so who
are the scribes the scribes are the
people who are actually copying out the
religious texts and they get to know
them very well as a result they're kind
of a community resource the Pharisees uh
which is you know later on going to
become this rabbinical movement right
that that's so closely identified with
Judaism throughout the centuries they
are rather popular religious teachers
who live a fairly strict life and are
you know looked at with respect by The
Ordinary People they're opposed to the
people who actually control the temple
the Sadducees Jesus goes after the
Pharisees a lot more because he's in
contact with them a lot more so you know
they have righteousness in some sense
because they're following the strict
codes of the law
but they're also lacking it in another
respect according to chrysostom how so
well he tells us here by righteousness
he means the whole of virtue and he
brings up job as an example of this he
was a blameless man righteous well what
does that actually mean you know so if
you think about how you follow rules or
laws or Commandments
you can do so by fulfilling the letter
of the law and doing what it says so you
know when it comes to Thou shalt not
kill or Thou shalt not murder one of the
Ten Commandments or ten words
um well don't kill anybody right or
don't murder anybody
um but that doesn't mean
that you're virtuous that just means
you're actually following a rule and
what Jesus is telling people is that
what God wants from them is something
more inward something that has to do
with how we feel and how we're motivated
and all of all of that sort of stuff and
so you know he's going to talk about the
old and the new as actually being of the
same tribe and Kindred they are not
separate uh in in kind from each other
right and so this is going to be quite
important and again this goes back to
opposing the manichaeans who would say
oh the Old Law very bad the new law very
good there's a radical separation
between them chrysostom like most
Orthodox Christians is interpreting it
as Jesus saying you got the Old Law
we're not taking that away we're not
even going to take one iota one little
Dot from the top of an eye from it but
rather we're going to add some stuff
that clarifies that uh you could say
expands the law and so these are not
completely separated from each other and
so he says you know we need to defend
the law against people who are attacking
it let us now ask those who reject the
law
is be not angry contrary to do no murder
do not kill or is the one commandment
the completion and the development of
the other and he says clearly the one is
namely be not angry the fulfilling of
the other and this is on the very
account why
well if you're not getting angry at
people uh then you're going to much more
refrain from murder and he who bridles
wrath will much more keep his hands to
himself for wrath is the root of murder
and he says if you cut the cut up the
root you will much more remove the
branches or you will not permit them as
much to shoot out as all right so he
says so he didn't come to abolish the
law
um he actually wanted a more complete
observation of the law what design did
the law enjoin these things was it not
that no one might slay as neighbors so
opposing the law would have to enjoy
neighbors killing your neighbor right
um and he says if you don't let a person
be even angry the mind of the law is
established by a more completely one
that studies to avoid murder will not
refrain from it equally with those whose
put away even anger now is Chris system
saying that the only reason people ever
murder each other is over anger no I
mean greed is another big one as well
but if you get rid of the anger or you
say don't give in to the anger you're
much more likely to follow the the uh
other part of the law and you could
think for example about biblical
examples the very first murder the very
first death in the Genesis story occurs
because of anger
says it right there in the text so this
is one important consideration and then
other people would argue that well the
Old Law is actually cruel it's it's not
nice you know what is the Old Law
actually say not only does it say don't
murder but it also says well if you do
murder then kill him right this goes all
the way back to Genesis as well it's one
of the rules that's given to to Noah and
then there's this other passage what we
often call the law of talion
um you know an eye for an eye a tooth
for a tooth so if somebody doesn't even
kill somebody but they knock their eye
out well you knock their eye out as well
and then we got two one-eyed people or
somebody who knocks somebody's tooth out
punching them in the face perhaps gets
their tooth knocked out and this sounds
kind of barbaric right and so the
mannequins could say
that's a bad old law we want to get past
that and leave that behind chrysostom is
very interestingly going to say you've
got this all wrong you've got the
perspective mixed up
is the Old Law evil no he says it's the
highest kind of philanthropy he talks
about it as stemming from Mercy or pity
you could say rather than from cruelty
how so he says he made this law not that
we might strike out each other's eyes
but that fear of suffering by others
might restrain us from doing any such
thing to them and he brings up the
example of the ninevites if you've ever
read the story of Jonah the prophet
who's you know gets swallowed by the
whale and spit up and all that sort of
stuff he's trying to avoid going to the
ninevites who are non-jewish people to
preach repentance and so you know
finally he gets there and he preaches he
wanders around the city and the
nunamites actually listen and they're
like yeah God's Gonna Smite us let's
actually start behaving properly and
then Jonah is ticked off himself sulking
under a tree because I didn't Smite the
ninevites and you know the moral of the
stories in part hey let God do what God
is going to do let's have let's
celebrate goodness instead so he says
um
therefore he threatened the ninevites
with overthrow not that he might destroy
them for had that been his will he
should have just been silent but that he
might by fear make them better and so
quiet his wrath and so he appointed a
punishment for those who wantonly assail
the eyes of others that if good
principle does not dispose them to
refrain from this cruelty fear might
restrain them from injuring their
neighbor's sight so you know instead of
it being a cruel rule it's actually God
keeping people in check a little bit
later
Chris's is going to say don't you see
how the commandments so far from coming
of Cruelty come rather of abounding
Mercy right and if on account of these
you call the law Giver Grievous and hard
to bear with tell me which kind of
command is more toilsome and Grievous do
no murder I mean do you have a hard time
not murdering people if you do well then
you've got trouble double or be not even
angry which is more an extreme he who
exacts a penalty for murder or for mere
anger right he also talks about the
adulterer but we're going to skip over
that here so he says whereas we say
there's but one in the same legislator
of either Covenant
[Music]
um
who dispensed all meatly and adapted to
the difference of the times the
difference between the two systems of
law so actually these these go together
and you could say well what if you know
what if you actually took away the law
it would be chaos it would be even worse
so it's not cruelty to impose this old
law but it's time to bring about a new
set of precepts that don't take away the
old law but rather fulfill it right so
the new precepts in a certain respect
are even more merciful and philanthropic
or loving of human beings than was the
Old Law by itself but if the Old Law
isn't being put away it's being
reinterpreted and expanded so this is uh
chrysostom's defense of both the Old and
the new law as kind of harmonized with
each other uh against you know two
polemical groups uh Jews who would say
well you don't need the new law this is
actually extra stuff and the mannequins
and other Gnostic Christians who would
say well the Old Law was all bad get rid
of it Christians want to observe or
Orthodox Christians want to observe both
of these and so that's why chrysostom is
explaining things this way